a closing keynote today I'm really
honored to excite honored and excited to
welcome is Obi Felton for our keynote
and the topic is about daring greatly
and how to fail gracefully on the way to
success
Obi leads early stage projects @x
alphabets moonshot Factory she works
with a team of inventors and
entrepreneurs engaged in projects like
self-driving cars way moe
drone delivery wing and balloon-powered
internet project loon Obi is responsible
for getting potentially world-changing
projects out of the lab and into the
real world and her twin commitments to
innovation and social good will sound
the perfect closing note for the day
please join me in welcoming Obi Sultan
[Applause]
[Music]
hello well it's wonderful I'm honored to
be here um so my job title is head of
getting moonshots ready for contact with
the real world which sounds like a joke
but it's my real title and hopefully by
the end of this talk it will make a
little bit more sense so what I'm going
to talk about today is failure and how
important failure is as a part of the
innovation and in fact any creative
process so this is a talk about failure
but not just any kind of failure it's
about how to deal with it well um and
that's really important by the way of
designing a new product or new campaign
or whether you just want to be a better
mother or a better leader or to
certainly things that I strive for every
single day so before I talk about how we
feel I'm gonna remind you what you we
work about work on at X so we work on
projects like this self-driving cars
which is now its own company called way
no delivery drones a project called wing
glass which came out of X and came back
recently and I'll talk a little bit
about that particular story cuz it's
very interesting a contact lens for
diabetics that measures the glucose in
your tear in your tears you don't have
to prick your finger to measure the
glucose levels that's now part of a
company called verily that also came out
of X Project loon the project that first
brought me to X Internet access from
balloon project Malta which is about
providing storage for all the wind and
solar energy that we produce when the
grid doesn't actually need it so that we
can store it and use it when it does
need it and carbon neutral fuel from
seawater a failed project that I'll tell
you about in a little bit so there was
great rumors when xf burnett first
leaked that x even existed when we were
still part of google and we were called
Google X the New York Times reported
that we're working on self-driving cars
and on a space elevator now those of you
who know physics know that space
elevators is really hard even harder
than self-driving cars so no we're not
working on those but of course we did
work
after in cars and Sebastian who you'll
hear from later was the founder not just
in Udacity but actually of that project
so you might wonder what draws these
kind of very disparate projects together
so this is our mission and our mission
is to invent and launch into the world
moonshot technologies that make the
world a radically better place and so
we're team of inventors and of engineers
but we also have product managers and
marketing people etc in our teams
because we don't want to just stop at
the inventing part in order to fulfill
the second part of the mission it's very
important that we actually launch and
get out into the world and you could
kind of put in brackets and we want to
build real businesses because we believe
that some of these problems are so big
that unless you build a business that
then scales by itself we don't think
they can actually be solved so that kind
of combination of purpose first and
profit is is also very important to us
so that kind of begs the question what
is the moonshot and this is now a word
that's been sort of thrown around quite
a bit when we started using it five
years ago we were kind of Hawking back
to the original moonshot in the 1960s
when Kennedy said we're going to put a
man on the moon we have no idea how but
we're going to try and that's sort of
what it feels like when we first start
our projects so the way we define a
moonshot as a technology moon front
Factory is as follows we start with a
huge problem in the world something that
sounds like that would affect millions
or even billions of people if it was
solved then we propose a radical
solution something that sounds like
science fiction today but we believe
that there's breakthrough technology
that's on the horizon and by this we
mean five to ten years so not two years
but also not 50 years or never that
would turn that science fiction into
reality
so that's a very simple concept but of
course it's not that easy in practice
and this kind of brings me to the
failure part because the path to success
is definitely littered with failure and
as you can hear from my accent I'm also
not from here
I grew up in Germany in Europe in a
country where failure is definitely
something that you were afraid of and
embarr
you know Germans do not like to go
bankrupt it's not part of the culture
this sort of same way that is in some
other cultures and we would sort of look
enviously to Silicon Valley where even
the failures seem to be celebrated as
heroes having lived here for five years
now I'm a I'm a registered decent import
I can tell you that's not true
and that's one of the great myths of the
valley I think even here the heroes are
the ones who succeed but I think it's
true that perhaps people here are better
at dealing with a failure maybe it's the
weather you know it's like much more
easy to be optimistic and be resilient
and bounce back if it's sunny all the
time and you know every entrepreneur you
meet here will tell you about their
successes and how great their product is
going in it every VC will tell you that
you know they've just funded the next
Google or Facebook or snapchat or
whatever it is right but but they do
kind of in private think about like you
know how come how can we come back from
failure so I would argue that fear of
failure failure is maybe the biggest
impediment to innovation much bigger
than lack of funds and that's because
these fears like run really really deep
we're afraid of losing our pride our
bonus a promotion and maybe even our job
right if the company that folds so I
lead early stage projects at X and you
can think of X as like a big funnel we
put lots of stuff in on the on the top
and most of the stuff in the beginning
fails and then at the end hopefully we
produce one way now right so because I
work at the top of the funnel most of
what I work on fails so I feel somewhat
qualified to talk about this so we're
constantly talking about you know what
project should we start which ones do we
continue and which ones do we pivot and
which ones to be shut down and how can
we make it psychologically safe for a
team to work in that kind of uncertain
environment so I definitely don't have
all the answers but I want to share with
you some of the lessons that I've learnt
along the way so my first first piece of
advice is just accept that you're going
to fail this is a great quote it's often
attributed to Edison
parent he's never said it but it's still
a great quote to be owdacious you
actually have to be humble
right you have to sort of expect that
most of what you are going to work on is
not going to work so that means that X
we don't aim for perfection on the first
girl and I think it really helps to
reframe the kind of like failing fast is
another one of those Silicon Valley
cliches that you sometimes hear people
talk about I don't think that's a useful
way of looking at it we don't want to
fail fast but we do want to learn very
fast and that X that means running at
the hardest part of the problem first so
let me give you an example of this and
imagine you want to train a monkey to
recite Shakespeare or Goethe or whatever
your poems are while starting on a
pedestal what do you do first
what do you work on first do you work on
the pedestal or do you work on training
the monkey okay monkey any what so the
the intuitive thing is actually most
people jump immediately to working on
the things that they know how they can
do so they make it to-do list
no we make a risk list and there we go
okay here's like the three things that
we know how to do so we can uh knock all
those out first and then we feel really
good because we've made terms of
progress and we can report that back to
our bosses or to our venture capitalists
or whoever work feel accountable to but
what if in the second year you find out
that it's actually impossible to train
the monkey you've wasted like a whole
year building this really beautiful
pedestal so when I first start a project
I asked the team to make a risk list and
I asked them to like rate east each risk
and how scared are you of this risk like
how comfortable are you that you can
like solve this and how important is it
so if this happens like will it sink the
project and then we work on the things
that will sink the project and are
really scary first right which is
actually incredibly counterintuitive so
let me give you an example from lune of
like how sometimes the biggest risk is
not very obvious in the beginning and
you have to kind of iterate on this list
so what do know is the project that
brought me to X just over five years ago
and the problem that we're working on
there
as to provide connectivity to the world
at the time when it first mooted there
was maybe two thirds of the world who
didn't have internet access now it's
still well over 50 percent so it's a
huge problem and it's especially
prevalent in remote areas in rural areas
and of course in poorer areas of the
world so a radical solution is to go up
so to build a network of balloons that
floats 20 kilometers high up in the
stratosphere and that's well above air
traffic you'll be relieved to know and
it's also well above the weather and
that sounded crazy which is why the team
is called loon and they actually call
themselves the loonies and to make it
work there to solve a lot of technical
challenges so the data transmission
between the balloons between your phone
and the balloon 20 kilometres up but
they also to work on making a balloon
and a turnout that leaks in the balloon
skin' were actually one of our biggest
problems that we had not expected so you
know the day after a birthday party when
like all the balloons are on the floor
that's kind of what it felt like to us I
did the first business model for loon
and we said the balloons would have to
last a hundred days for the economics to
work and the first balloons lasted five
days so that was a pretty big gap so we
set up a team led by Pam she's the head
/ lunatic and she she set up this leak
squad and they studied other products
that where leaks were important like
chips packets or sausage casings or even
condoms and they ran lots and lots of
experiments to find out what was causing
the leaks and one of them they did in
our balloon factory where they realized
that people were walking around on the
material during the manufacturing
process so they did a line dance on the
balloon material one in normal socks and
one in fluffy socks an eternity s the
fluffy socks were less damaging to the
balloon material now that's a you know a
funny experiment but the reality was
that actually the manufacturing process
was much more important than we thought
at first so back in the lab they built a
huge giant inspection table it's called
Billie Jean don't ask me why but Billie
Jean is a large and whenever balloon
comes back down from the stratosphere
the team actually puts it out
laser out on on to the inspection table
and we inspect things and the joke with
a shark slippers is that again you know
allowed to walk around on Billie Jean or
on the balloon material unless you have
appropriate shoe wear so in in 2013 loon
actually did its first test flights in
New Zealand and we connected a sheep
farmer for a very short period of time
he's caught Charles and his first things
he did is you check the weather very
important for sheep farmers and he
checked his Facebook also apparently
very important to Charles and I actually
wasn't there because I had a baby I was
pregnant at the time so I had a bet to
the engineers about who was gonna launch
first me or them and of course they were
ten days late and my daughter was ten
days early so I won but the Loon team
has come a really long way since that
sort of first set of flights in New
Zealand we've now balloons now survived
over one hundred and ninety days in the
stratosphere and they also flown about
twenty nine million kilometres and so
now it's time for them to actually make
contact with the real world so back in
September Hurricane Maria devastated the
island of Puerto Rico and pretty much
the entire infrastructure was wiped out
including telecoms we actually have a
launch site in Puerto Rico so the team
immediately said what can we do to help
but in order to help to connect with
people on the ground we needed a telco
partner because our business model is
not to direct directly am sell to
consumers but to provide bandwidth to a
cap telco so within three weeks which
must be like a record we'd signed a deal
with both AT&T and with t-mobile and we
helped to restore connectivity on the
ground we actually had to use our other
launch site which is in Winnemucca in
the US and fly the balloons there
because they're priority or eco one was
too damaged and so we connected about
two hundred thousand people and in the
whole since twenty seventeen we've
connected about three hundred thousand
people and and serve terabytes of data
so that's kind of like the first real
test and it's amazing for a project that
five years ago everyone thought it was
completely crazy it turns out yes you
can give people internet from balloons
so that theme of making contact with the
real world and following
the problem that you're solving not the
technology because the technology might
change is also really important
before I X I worked at Google so I
worked mostly on software and there it's
really easy to iterate right like we
work on software and hardware and it's
much much harder to iterate that
hardware but it's still comedian and a
really good example of a team that
iterated a lot was actually the glass
team so they built a new prototype every
four to six weeks so that enabled them
to go from the thing that you see on the
left which is like a dude in a sort of
Robocop outfit with a laptop in the back
that powers the the device to prototype
that on the right that looks almost like
the final prototype that we sent out
into the world and that was still very
much a prototype but the engineering
team knew that as soon as people would
leave the building with it it would leak
right because it was so conspicuous so
what they did what the team did is they
launched what they called an Explorer
program so they sent out the devices are
there so devices to to the first you
know few hundred users and they were
really widespread so it's from doctors
to parents to engineers to fashion model
of etc and they asked them for feedback
and the feedback that we got back from
these explorers who were definitely sort
of intrepid explorers like lots of stuff
didn't work about the device was
manifold so first of all they told us
about their hardware they said the
battery life stocked and they said the
UI was really hard to use because it was
based on voice and fine next four years
or five years four and a half years ago
voice was still not that great right
it's still not perfect but certainly a
lot better but they also gave us a lot
of useful feedback on the use cases so
it turned out that from consumers use
cases like this are really charming this
was actually a picture of Sebastian
Thrun son so Sebastian took it and he's
spinning in hands-free right and that's
really wonderful
but it's probably not enough to make you
want to wear a computer on your face all
day long so there was quite a backlash
against the consumer product people were
being called glass halls they were being
thrown out of out of out of bars because
people thought they would be permanently
during them little did they know the
battery would have lasted about three
minutes if you were permanently videoing
but it was a completely different story
on the BTB side so for b2b customers it
didn't matter that the battery didn't
last that long they're just like carried
a battery pack right and they found all
sorts of interesting use cases even
though we didn't market to them and we
in fact initially said no you shouldn't
be using this in a work environment so
it was factory floors and warehouses and
doctor surgeries where people found all
sorts of interesting use cases they use
them in training to display training
materials to people so booing for
instance when they assemble a plane the
manuals are about this high and instead
they can dissipate just a bit that
people need while they're assembling a
particular part on on glass doctors used
it to watch patient notes so instead of
looking at a computer they could still
look you in the eye while they're having
their consultation and so over the past
two years after the glass team sort of
went into hiding you know after all this
backlash happened they were quietly
working with about 30 different
companies who were using glass and then
they relaunched last summer as a b2b
product now that was a completely
unexpected pivot there's no way that if
we had stayed in the lab the team could
have predicted that right and there was
only through listening to users who told
us what this technology was actually
most useful for that we managed to do
that so that's a kind of phoenix from
the ashes somewhat story right like
sometimes it works out that way but
sometimes it doesn't and one of the
toughest things for an entrepreneur is
actually to know when to call it quits
and here's my top tip for that all of us
set success criteria when we first start
a project right like you it's very easy
to imagine what the world will look like
if you succeed my advice is you should
also at that point and the very
beginning set some kill criteria so if
this thing happens I will shut my own
project down and those can be business
criteria around costs they can be
technical criteria around round trip
efficiency fund stands for a particular
process it's just really important that
they're measurable and that you as a
team agree on what they are
and when it when these kill criteria hit
it makes it a much less emotional
decision to shut the project down and in
fact it means that the team can do do
this themselves so let me tell you the
story of one of my favorite projects
which is called foghorn so far God's
goal was to make carbon neutral fuel
from seawater so he extracts co2 from
sea water combine it with renewable
Emily made hydrogen to make a synthetic
fuel and then that fuel is burnt in any
combustion engine and you could put it
pretty much into any engine without
retrofitting that co2 gets released back
in into the atmosphere but it's a closed
carbon cycle right so you effectively
making the the burning carbon neutral
you're not putting extra co2 into the
into the atmosphere so that sounded
amazing right there's over a billion
cars in the world they're not all going
to be replaced by electric cars
overnight and for some like heavy goods
vehicles like trucks it's debatable
whether they can ever run on batteries
so I loved it so it was an amazing idea
and the team figured out many technical
challenges we worked this New York spark
which is an Innovation Lab just up the
road here and we actually build a
machine so you can see here on the left
is a bucket of ocean so that's the
seawater coming in and then on the right
you see Cathy Cooper Hannah and who was
the project lead and she's holding a
little vial of the sea fuel that we made
when we started the project we also set
an economic criteria and you might be
able to guess what this is yeah so we
started in 2012 and oil was about $100 a
barrel and when the when oil hits $30 a
barrel the team came to means that
there's like no way we can make this
work and we debated for a while over
whether you know we should try and bet
on commodity prices changing etc and in
the end like we didn't and I'm glad we
didn't because oil is still pretty low
so the team decided to kill their own
project for that decision I gave him a
bonus which HR first said what you're
giving them a bonus for failing and I
said no I'm giving them bonus for like
making the decision to shut down their
own project you know that's very brave
and I want to reward that kind of
behavior plus they gave me a whole bunch
of
budget back which was less a lot more
than the bottom the bonus and they've
written up their work and they submitted
it to two peer-reviewed journals and the
papers have actually just come out so we
kind of hope that maybe it's just
deep-frozen and someone will see
something that we've overlooked after
foghorn closed down Cathy Cooper started
another project which is around
geothermal heating and cooling and she
actually just spun that out last year
out of X as a start-up so she went on to
become a CEO of a start-up which is
super awesome and to her personal story
there they moved to New York so if you
know anyone in upstate New York that
needs new heating and cooling sandy line
so far talk mostly about sort of some of
the rational ways that we can make it
easier to both acknowledge like when
something's not going to work out and
and how to make it easier for the team
to ignore is that right things like
setting kill criteria up front giving
people bonuses you know doing
post-mortems like talking about
celebrating the lessons from failure not
the failure itself you know all really
important parts of our culture but
they're still and we also for instance
do things like we decoupled promotions
from project success so we were just
debating promotions this morning and
we're very careful to not penalize
people working on some a thing that
didn't work out because they might have
still done really great work but we also
have to acknowledge that there's always
an emotional side to failure right so
whatever happens there's some sort of
grief process that the teams go through
and oh actually forget to that there's
like one way that we deal with is also
humor so we the rapid eval team which is
the beginning of the funnel that I
described right where they kill almost
everything they work on all they get is
a little sticker with a crumpled piece
of paper on it because they kill so many
things and then there's a little
competition amongst the team like who
can get more of these stickers on to
that laptop but the grief process is
very real that you know you have to kind
of let go of something you've worked on
for a while that you're very passionate
about and this is actually a model from
the 1960s by a psychologist called
Elizabeth kubler-ross and she talks
about the stages of grief when a loved
one dies
and if you look at those stages like
shock denial anger bargaining depression
and then eventually you get through to
acceptance and it's not necessarily
linear people sort of move around back
and forth in this that is actually what
we go through as well when one of our
projects dies and the longer you've
worked on something the more passionate
about your the longer you need to give
yourself time to kind of grieve properly
so at X we actually have a whole day now
like when the world celebrates Dia de
los Muertos we celebrate it at X as a
very kind of serious to the Latin
tradition and that's when we let go of
our projects so in closing I don't have
to tell you that innovation is messy
right I think I think we all know that
and the key I really think it yields an
IKE how we deal with inevitable failures
that we encounter on the way to the moon
and I got a great analogy from a friend
who used to work for Bell Labs
she's got Mara and coke and she said you
know when we're kids and we learn to
walk we fall over all the time and we
stumble and we just pick ourselves back
up again and it's a completely normal
thing but somewhere when we became
adults we think that if we stumble and
we fall it's a really big deal and we're
embarrassed and you know it's awful so
maybe we can kind of get back to some of
that childlike thing and I want to close
with one of my favorite quotes which is
from Roosevelt speech that he delivered
at the Sorbonne in 1910 and I'll read
you the passage it's not the critic who
counts not the man who points out how
the strong man stumbles or where the
doer of Deeds could have done better the
credit belongs to the man who is
actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and blood who
strives valiantly who errs who comes
short again and again because there's no
effort without error and shortcoming but
who does actually strive to do the deeds
who knows great enthusiasms the great
devotions who spends himself in a worthy
cause and who are the best knows in the
end the triumph of high achievement and
who at the worst if he fails at least he
fails
while daring greatly so that his place
shall never be with those cold and timid
souls who neither know victory nor
defeat
thank you
[Applause]